[Musique]
j'espère que ça se sera instable et que
tu vas pouvoir travailler ce vendredi 10
avril au collège titans du port dix
familles se sont vu remettre des
tablettes numériques afin de poursuivre
leur scolarité durant la période du
confinement après de matériel issu d'une
convention signée entre le département
et l'académie de la réunion en direction
des élèves prioritairement pour c'est
tout simplement pour que nos jeunes
puissent continuer à travailler et
réussir leur avenir
donc je trouve que c'est une très belle
initiative non seulement de la part de
l'état mais de la part d'une département
de la collectivité de vouloir
accompagner la jeunesse réunionnaise
alors c'est important de le faire
puisque monsieur le recteur était très
attentif à ce que cette continuité
pédagogique puisse
irrigué l'ensemble du territoire
peu importe le lieu comme peu importe le
niveau social des familles donc de ce
fait travailler avec le département
était une idée évidente des tablettes
mise à disposition des établissements
pour l'enseignement numérique des
collégiens
les principaux sont responsables de la
répartition du matériel mon
établissement est un établissement qui
relèvent de l'éducation prioritaire
renforcée donc j'ai envie de vous dire
que sur mes 147 enfants qui viennent
récupérer les cours les documents
pédagogiques papier ils sont tous
beaussier tôt 3 voire tôt 2 donc déjà je
vais pouvoir servir ces familles là
ensuite les autres nous verrons après la
distribution chaque famille a bénéficié
d'une présentation pour une première
prise en main du matériel
après deux tablettes qui représente un
véritable coup de pouce pour ces élèves
c'est de bien travailler et de faire de
l'exercice et c'est de pouvoir rhône +8
6% par rapport à l'ordinateur que ça
donne beaucoup et c'est vrai moyen plus
facile
de travailler avec les profs et des ces
deux gouttes d'eau
vidéo entre les prophéties maintenant le
contact
le comptable est prof tout de pouvoir
travailler à la maison on accepter
maintenant on n'a pas tous thématiques
où elle avait du mal à travailler là
elle va pouvoir faire ses devoirs
tranquillement à la maison
cette distribution s'est déroulée dans
52 autres collèges de l'île
au total 4500 tablettes ont ainsi été
prêté aux élèves
[Musique]